nasa tells us today it's found a new
planet they have found seven seven
planets as many as fifty five hundred
thirty five hundred planets they're
pretty sure that they're rocky planets
every one of them could have liquid
water scientists calling the discovery
quote very exciting stuff very exciting
i am very excited i'm excited it's just
really
this is so fascinating i'm also excited
but i've always wondered how do people
find these little exoplanets from
trillions of miles away and how could
they possibly figure out anything about
them their size their composition if
they'd be a nice place to live
well here's how
it's possible to study some things in
space by just taking pictures of them
but that works best for really close
things or really big things seeing a
planet around a star is much much harder
the problem with exoplanets is they're
right next to
a big bright massive star and that star
overwhelms the planet when we point our
most powerful telescopes at stars that
are similar to our sun we get images
like this
these pixels are capturing the glare of
starlight but the star is actually much
smaller and any planets would be smaller
still for example if our sun were the
size of this ball the earth would be
this big if we're talking diameter the
earth is about a hundred times smaller
than the sun but the light reflecting
off it is 10 billion times dimmer than
the sun so of course it would get lost
in the glare
it's like looking for a firefly next to
stadium floodlights
in the 70s and 80s astronomers set out
to find a way around this problem at
that time everyone was excited about
finding intelligent life we launched two
interstellar probes that carried
messages for aliens giant radar dishes
started listening for voices from outer
space and e.t became the highest
grossing movie of all time
but embarrassingly scientists had yet to
find a single planet around another star
they had a pretty clear wish list first
just confirmed the existence of a planet
second find the size of its orbit
we'd really like to know the distance
from the star so we can understand how
warm the planet is is it a boiling
hellscape too close to its sun like
mercury too distant like jupiter's
frozen moon europa or just right the
kind of place that could have liquid
water
third it would be nice to know how dense
the planet is is it a giant planet like
jupiter made mostly of hydrogen and
helium or is it one of the prized rocky
planets that's mostly heavier more dense
material
and most of all but hardest to do
we'd like to find gases in the
atmosphere that might be associated with
life
oxygen is a fantastic biosignature gas
our atmosphere is full of it thanks to
plants and photosynthetic bacteria
and if there were an intelligent alien
civilization looking back at us
they'll be suspicious that something is
here
it won't be our city lights
or the great wall of china
it will be oxygen actually
so the goal was to find a planet
describe its orbit and its density and
search for signs of life all just by
looking at this
to
detect or study
an exoplanet we have to work with the
star
we sometimes think of our solar system
where our sun is a fixed point and that
all the planets are orbiting the sun but
a correction to the picture is our sun
is not exactly fixed the sun pulls on
the planets but the planets pull back
the planets and sun are orbiting what we
call their common center of mass and
that makes the sun wobble back and forth
a huge planet will make the star wobble
a lot and a lower mass planet will make
the star wobble much less
we just had to wait for technology to
get sensitive enough to pick up those
wobbles
in 1995 swiss astronomers announced that
a star in the pegasus constellation had
an oscillation that repeated every 4.23
days
with just those data points the basics
of how gravity works and some simple
math they calculated that there was a
planet only 4 million miles away from
the star that's incredibly close
compared to our solar system and it was
about the size of jupiter
soon the wobble method was turning up
dozens of planets and at the same time
revealing their distance from their
stars
but this method couldn't deliver the
precise mass or size measurements needed
to calculate density
luckily there's another way we can
indirectly detect planets just by
staring at their stars
so some planetary systems are aligned
just so such that the planet goes in
front of the star as seen from our
telescope a so-called transit and that's
fantastic because we can monitor the
brightness of the star
and look for a tiny tiny drop in
brightness that might mean a planet is
going in front of the star
our jupiter's transit signal on our sun
is one percent
here's what that one percent drop would
look like in our view of a distant star
pretty hard to see so for our earth and
sun it's about one part in ten thousand
in the 1980s no one knew how to detect a
change that small and most astronomers
concluded that this so-called transit
method was not practical as a primary
detection technique
it's very rare for a planetary system to
be so perfectly aligned that we can see
the transit so we must monitor
lots of stars tens of thousands or even
hundreds of thousands of stars at a
single time and of course just seeing
one drop in brightness isn't enough you
have to wait around for a second transit
to know how long the orbit takes if you
were looking for earth that means you'd
have to wait for at least a full year
it's hard it's hard to find long period
planets with the transit method because
you have to be staring at one place for
a very long time but as before it was
only a matter of time
in 2001 a research team was watching 5
million stars in the neighborhood of
sagittarius and they picked up a dip in
the brightness of this one
luckily they didn't have to wait around
long for a second transit because the
planet they found shot around its star
every 29
hours
the telescope they used was on the
ground which meant it had to peer
through earth's turbulent atmosphere not
exactly ideal but the kepler space
telescope launched in 2009 was literally
above all that it watched one patch of
sky for years and found thousands of
planets
not only was this a good detection
technique it could also be used to
figure out the precise mass of the
planet and its size too the bigger the
planet the bigger the drop in brightness
and with those elements you could
finally calculate density
so far we've found nearly 5 000 planets
hundreds are likely rocky worlds like
earth and dozens of those seem to be in
the habitable zones of their stars
incredibly the question has shifted from
do any stars have planets to do any
stars not have planets
but we're still looking for signs of
life
how well back in 1999 sarah proposed a
way to investigate the gases in
exoplanet atmospheres when that planet
goes in front of the star
some of the star light shines through
the atmosphere different gases in that
atmosphere would absorb different
wavelengths of light
for example a simple molecule like
hydrogen gas absorbs these paints other
compounds have more complex signatures
sarah's idea was to look for those tiny
signals once that starlight reached
earth but not everybody was on board so
one place i applied for a job
a professor sat across from me and
literally said i just
i just don't think we're going to have
very many transiting planets they didn't
think we'd be able to study atmospheres
they didn't think the field was going to
go anywhere
at least one team
ran with the idea to use the hubble
space telescope and succeeded in
observing the first exoplanet atmosphere
unfortunately it looks like this
technique works best when the star is
small and the planet is big earth-sized
planets transiting sun-like stars have
such a tiny signal and their atmospheres
have an even tinier signal that we may
never be able to observe it's like the
skin of an onion on an onion
we need to move beyond transits to a
different technique we call this
technique direct imaging okay i know we
started down this whole wobble and
transit path because taking a picture of
an exoplanet seemed impossible but look
at this this is a real time lapse of
planets orbiting a star the trick was to
block out the star's overwhelming glare
with a device called a coronagraph
now this view is only possible because
the planets are a really huge b really
far from their star here's our solar
system for comparison and c they're all
glowing red hot
we want to make direct imaging better
and better so we can move down to
smaller and smaller and cooler planets
and to do this we have to go to space
to get above the blurring effects of
earth's atmosphere
and we want to use starshade
starshade sounds like a teen fantasy
series
[Music]
but it's actually a proposed
space-faring parasol kind of like a
free-floating coronagraph starshade
would be about the size of a baseball
diamond but they tested it out using
this model its strange flower-like shape
would stop the starlight from bending
around the edges and overwhelming the
telescope
and it has to formation fly
tens of thousands of kilometers from a
telescope
the star shade and telescope will line
up perfectly like in a very very
straight line together with the target
star
this giant space flower would have to be
launched inside a much narrower rocket
so nasa has turned to origami for
inspiration
[Music]
but it's not clear when or if starshade
will get off the ground at the end of
2021 the u.s astronomical community laid
out their priorities in an official
report the report went through rigorous
peer review and represents the consensus
view of the steering committee these
so-called decadal surveys are hugely
important in previous decades they've
advocated for hubble and the recently
launched james webb space telescope for
this decade our highest priority
is a telescope for observing habitable
exoplanets
but the report didn't advocate for a
starshade mission this decade
so first of course i was really
disappointed but we'll see you know if
it doesn't go with this next telescope
someday it will go it will go
having this attitude that i'm going to
explore i'm going to do this anyway it's
really key in the field of exoplanets so
about a decade later i went back
and somehow on my schedule was the same
professor and he just welcomed me into
his office and he just said exoplanets
i always knew it was going to be big
i was just like
[Music]